i love it when big men act like little
kids and they're so happy dave grow you
know that feeling look look who we just
found hanging in the green room how
about that look at him dave nothing
better to do come hang out
well you had something better to do but
we were better than that thank you dave
dave is here for his first tv interview
why because he's revealing a new memoir
it's called the storyteller tales of
life and music it's a collection of
moments from childhood to fatherhood
fatherhood what a life this guy has had
it covers life on the road and playing
alongside rock and roll's greatest
musicians like
paul mccartney role is his 16-time
grammy award winner he's a member of the
rock and roll hall of fame thank you
very much he was a drummer for the band
nirvana we know that and his lead singer
are of our executive producers
favorite rock band oh that's new in the
copy
but dave that is not why you're here
because shauna thomas loves you you're
here because you are dave grohl and this
is a fantastic book so welcome welcome
welcome very much but this is the thing
i was reading the book and i'm thinking
if it wasn't for covet a we wouldn't
have a book
and two if it wasn't for sandy who broke
your heart when you were in high school
you might not have been a famous
musician true
well give the back story okay so i
started playing music when i was like 10
years old yeah
and started playing guitar i learned
from uh beatles records and beatles song
books and playing along to the albums
and stuff
and um
when i was in seventh grade
first day of school i see this girl yeah
and she's sandy she's so beautiful and
it was like it was the first time my
heart had done that
like i need to make her mine you know
but i was such a skinny nerdy little
dude that i was not george clooney you
know i was just this
and so i asked her to go steady with me
and we like walk through the halls and
hold hands and stuff after about a week
she's like
you know
i'm new here and i don't want to tie
down and you know and my heart for the
first time really just kind of broke
yeah
and uh that night i had this dream
that i was in a band and i was in an
arena and i was doing a guitar solo
and the audience is like wow
and i looked down and i saw her in the
front row and she was crying this isn't
my dream yeah and uh
i saw it was that moment i woke up and i
thought okay
i think maybe this is how it works like
now that i can channel my heartbreak
into my instrument and like i was
inspired to write to like to get rid of
the pain of losing sandy well i think
it's good that worked out because you
also talked about you were not a good
student you you include your report card
here that says dave g rushes through
david g russia's who work inaccurate
messy does not turn in much of the
required work it's all right so
i mean
on the plus side though yeah
and they're going in your mind and your
point is but you knew at a very early
age that music you said you see life in
music you see moments in music and this
book is certainly a an example of that
well you know my mother she was a public
school teacher for 35 years and
she was really supportive of
me as a musician i think she understood
that this was my this is my passion this
is the one thing i was putting all my
energy into
even as my grades were slipping
you know she tried to do she did her
best to try to keep me like in the books
and keep me doing my thing but there was
nothing that was going to get in between
me and my instrument and she forever uh
supported and was very like facilitated
and dad not so much well my dad was a
conservative republican uh
speechwriter and journalist and he was
also a classically trained musician
so he you know he was a flautist and um
so i think we had two different ideas of
of what music was and how to do it
but i was born with his dna yeah and so
i got so he's in here yeah and so we
kind of went like this for a while until
later on in life we both became like
great friends and had a great
appreciation for you so by the time
you're 18 you're out of the house you're
on the road with scream you and two high
school buddies
and you're out on the west coast and you
get an invitation to try out with this
band nirvana which had already had an
album out they were a big deal at least
among musicians um but going to the
tryout means leaving your two best
buddies who you went on this adventure
with that's a really hard choice for
people yeah you call your mother what
advice did she get once again mom comes
mom
i mean she's she is a constant in this
this changed your life this decision it
did she um
i didn't know what to do because i was
at a crossroads and it's those times in
life where
those decisions are scary because you
have to live with the consequence of
that decision but what i when i asked my
mother i said what should i do she said
sometimes in life you have to do what's
best for yourself and i think she had
done that before in her life although
she was the most like altruistic most
giving generous person i'd ever met
she was telling me that sometimes you
have to do what's best for you yeah and
if if that was if that was good enough
for her then that's very good advice i
want to go back to your younger days
because you said you went to your first
punk rock show when you were young and
here's the quote i love i'd been
baptized by spit
sweat and broken glass
what was that moment like well so when i
was a kid like in my bedroom i had these
posters on my walls i had like led
zeppelin posters and i had kiss posters
and it was all like lasers and dragons
and smoke machines so that's what i
thought rock and roll was but i'd never
been to a concert so i went to this punk
rock show when i was 13 years old in
chicago
and i walked in and it was just this
small room
with maybe a couple lights and there was
a band they were called naked ray gun
with a couple amps on stage and they
countered into the song it was like well
dude and the place just exploded and it
was so raw and it was so real that i
thought oh this is rock and roll and
they only know four chords i only know
four chords so i could do this too and
that was the first day of the rest of my
life i was like you're the ultimate dad
girl because you have a girl dad because
you've got three daughters yes
here they are they are right there
there's harper there's violet ophelia
who goes by the name fifi i think this
is so cute one of the most touching
stories is you and violet because violet
is playing at her at her school yeah you
all decide to do blackbird and you said
you were more nervous doing that with
her than anything which surprised me
because you are dave grohl
why well here's the thing i mean you
know over the years you know you hit
these these milestones where it's like
okay now you're playing arenas now
you're playing stadiums now you're on
saturday night live these big big
moments
academy awards huge moments yeah but
when your daughter wants to get on stage
for the first time and sing a song yes
and you're doing blackbird by the
beatles yeah it's like that was the most
nervous i'd ever been in my entire life
because i was there to back her up in
front of her teachers and her friends
and everybody's watching oh my god and
then so we do that at the at the
talent show then i get a call to do it
on the academy awards and that and i was
nervous about that but violet says you
have to do it i love how you wrote about
kurt cobain is that hard for you it must
have been hard for you absolutely that
was the last chapter i wrote um
i had waited
for a year to write that because i was
afraid to write it yeah and um
yeah you know i mean
over the years i've lost more than a few
people that i've loved and been close to
it's hard to put that into words you
know rather than just kind of write
about what happened it's like
i wrote about
the emotional
process of of uh dealing with loss and
mourning and
and uh and how you how it's a lifetime
of healing yeah and the connection that
you made but you tell a great story i i
know we're going john but you tell a
great story where you said you were
trying to decide what to do after his
death you go to ireland you're in a
remote area
a guy is hitchhiking guys and he's
wearing uh he's wearing a kurt cobain
t-shirt and i said that's a lot of money
and i looked at him and i thought like
that you know what i gotta get home and
start over yeah the book is david the
book yeah stories you're a storyteller
something tells me there's gonna be a
part two just throwing it out there
every day is a story to me do without
what you will dave grill
the storyteller tales of life and music
comes out tomorrow wherever you like to
buy your books